[Music]
in the celestial court of the jade
emperor lived seven princesses
each had their chosen place in court but
the youngest princess had a special
skill
she could pluck clouds from the sky and
spin them into the softest robes her
work was so precise not even the most
expert eye could find a scene
but her craft was the same
day after day and she longed for new
inspiration
finally the queen mother granted the
weaver permission to visit earth
the other princesses would accompany her
to protect their sister from earthly
dangers
dressed in special robes that allowed
them to fly between heaven and earth the
sisters soared down from the sky
the weaver was in awe of the rolling
hills and rivers and the sisters decided
to swim in one of the glittering streams
as the weaver floated she dreamt about
staying forever
meanwhile a lone cow herd approached the
riverbank
he came here often to sweep his parents
grave and speak with his only companion
a stoic bull who listened patiently to
the cowherd
sorrows but upon seeing the weaver's
beauty the cowherd forgot his routine
while he longed to introduce himself his
lonely lifestyle had made him timid
thankfully the bill saw his friend's
plight and offered some advice
he told the cowherd of the swimmer's
celestial origins and of her dream to
stay on earth
but also that she could only remain if
she lost her ticket back to heaven
as the cow had approached the princesses
flew away in fear
leaving their dreaming sister behind
while keeping her magic robes hidden the
cow had offered his own garment as a
substitute and after gaining her trust
the pair began exploring the countryside
she was struck by his caring nature and
he learned to see the world's wonder
through her eyes
before long the two had fallen deeply in
love
the weaver and the cowherd built a
prosperous life
their farm flourished and the weaver
taught her skills to local
villagers as time marched on the pair
was blessed with two healthy children
but their bull was growing old
before he died the bull implored the
family to keep his hide and use its
magic at their time of need
[Music]
while the husband grieved for his friend
the weaver's mind turned to her other
family
dusting off her magical road she decided
to pay a visit to the heavens
but when the weaver swept into her old
home
no one seemed surprised to see her
with the start she realized that barely
any time had passed
for a year on earth was merely a day
in heaven
when her family learned of her new life
they were enraged how dare she waste her
love on a human the weaver tried to
escape back to earth but the queen
mother plucked a golden hairpin from her
head and tore through the sky
a great gulf opened forming a river of
stars between heaven and earth
below the cow herd trembled but he also
remembered the bull's final
words hastily placing each child in a
basket he draped the bull's pelt over
his back and hurtled upwards
above the clouds each lover attempted to
wade through the surging stars but no
matter how hard they struggled the gulf
between them only grew wider
day after day the queen mother watched
without pity
years passed and the weaver and the cow
herd had no one except the passing
magpies to cheer them on
finally their love moved the queen
mother's heart
while she couldn't forgive her
granddaughter entirely the queen mother
would allow the weaver to meet her
earthly family once a year
and so
in late summer the magpies form a bridge
across the milky way
reuniting the weaver and the cowherd
at this time of year millions of people
in east and southeast asian countries
tell similar tales of these star-crossed
lovers
celebrating their annual reunion
when gods fall in love with mortals it
always spells trouble
so what happens when they fall in love
with demons
watch the tale of the white snake and
her one true love to find out
[Music]